hey guys my name is Jeff and you're
watching games but news danny is off
sick today so do send him your
well-wishing down in that comment box
but for now here's what's been happening
[Music]
first up Microsoft has revealed exactly
when you'll be able to start playing
player and learns battlegrounds on Xbox
one depending on where you live the
rollout kicks off in New Zealand at 5:00
a.m. Pt on December the 11th and runs
through until servers go live in Mexico
at 10:00 p.m. Pt on the same day in a
blog post Xbox is Major Nelson pointed
out that those in Australia and New
Zealand may have trouble finding matches
early on but this should be rectified
when the game rolls out across the globe
you can check out the full global
release schedule in our story on site
Microsoft also revealed details on pub
G's Xbox controls the publisher noted
that it worked with the Xbox advanced
technology group and Gears avoid death
the Coalition on a set up that will
provide quote enough flexibility to
survive in the hostile battleground and
to effectively manage in-game equipment
on the fly you can head to GameSpot to
check out all the specifics if you came
for an early edge if you're as excited
as I am for haze lights upcoming game
away out then you'll be equally as
excited to hear that if you play with a
pallet you only need to buy the game
once Josef IRAs maker of awesome games
and dude who apparently hates the Oscars
sent out a tweet today saying if you
want to play a way out with your friend
online you only buy one copy adding the
stellar hashtag buying two copies so I
think we can add buying two copies to
the list of things fires isn't a fan of
haze Lite previously maybe incredible
brothers a tale of two sons and a way
out is already turning heads with its
prison breakout story designed to be
played in Corp split-screen let me know
what you think about it down in that
comment box finally Assassin's Creed
origins is getting a new update which is
adding a nightmare difficulty mode among
other things the 1.1 patch weighs in at
3 gigabytes on ps4 and Xbox one while
the size for PC is yet to be determined
it will be arriving on all platforms
tomorrow apart from the higher
difficulty option the update adds an NPC
scaling option which makes weaker
enemies match your current power level
there's also a new horde mode coming to
the arena and support for HDR displays
on piece
see beyond that the update provides a
number of fixes to graphical bugs the UI
general glitches and something that
reads a fixed an issue that could
prevent hallucinations from ending
during time hotep song pattern is the
best that is everything I got for you
guys today do let me know what you cared
about down in that comment box I will be
back same time tomorrow